un círculo tiene su centro en el punto
ce cuyas coordenadas son menos 1 menos 3
y tiene un radio de 6 dónde está el
punto p cuyas coordenadas son menos 6
menos 6 y tenemos tres opciones adentro
del círculo en el círculo y fuera del
círculo y la cuestión clave aquí es
encontrar en donde se encuentra el
círculo si tenemos el punto ce que es el
centro del círculo
este es el radio de 6 unidades y el
círculo va a lucir más o menos así
recuerden que un círculo es el conjunto
de todos los puntos que se encuentran a
exactamente 6 unidades de distancia del
centro esta es la definición de un
círculo así que sí p por ejemplo
estuviera a menos de 6 unidades de
distancia del centro estaría adentro del
círculo si está exactamente a 6 unidades
de distancia entonces estará en el
círculo y si está a una distancia mayor
de 6 unidades estará afuera del círculo
así que podemos encontrar la distancia
entre estos dos puntos
y si esta distancia es menor a 6
unidades el punto estará adentro si la
distancia es exactamente igual a 6
unidades estará en el círculo y si es
mayor a 6 unidades estará afuera del
círculo vamos a hacerlo tenemos
diferentes notaciones para la distancia
podemos escribir así la distancia entre
s&p que es igual a la fórmula de la
distancia viene directamente del teorema
de pitágoras es la raíz cuadrada de
nuestro cambio en x al cuadrado más
nuestro cambio en al cuadrado cuál es
nuestro cambio en x bueno si vemos hacer
como nuestro punto inicial y apec como
nuestro punto final aunque podríamos
hacerlo al revés nuestro cambio en x va
a ser menos 6 - menos 1 que esto está al
cuadrado lo que tenemos aquí es el
cambio en x esto es nuestro cambio en x
al cuadrado más nuestro cambio en al
cuadrado que es vamos de menos tres a
menos seis por lo que nuestro cambio en
sí es menos seis menos menos tres esto
al cuadrado esto es el cambio en y aquí
adentro del paréntesis
que elevamos al cuadrado y esto es igual
a la raíz cuadrada esto es igual a menos
seis más uno menos por menos es más
menos cinco al cuadrado más menos seis
más tres menos por menos es más nos
quedan menos tres al cuadrado y pueden
ver que nuestro cambio en x es menos 5
ya que vamos 5 por debajo en x y vamos 3
por debajo de este menos 3 y por eso
nuestro cambio en que es menos tres esto
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 25-9 que
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 34 ahora
aquí la cuestión es ver si esta raíz
cuadrada de 34 es menor igual o mayor
que 6 bueno sabemos que 6 es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 36
por lo que la raíz cuadrada de 34 es
menor que la raíz cuadrada de 36 por lo
que la raíz cuadrada de 34 es menor que
6 estos dos son iguales ya que la raíz
cuadrada de 36 es 6 y ya que la
distancia entre pse y pp es menor que 6
entonces este punto p se encuentra
adentro del círculo
si aquí de alguna manera me hubiera
quedado igual a la raíz cuadrada de 36
entonces mi punto p estaría en el
círculo y si por ejemplo aquí hubiera
tenido la raíz cuadrada de 37 o algo más
grande nuestro punto hubiera quedado
afuera del círculo